[La musique]
ce que la volonté des électeurs a exprimé 59 pour cent
des Allemands ont dit que nous voulons du changement
il n'y a pas que le personnel qui
Merkel n'est plus au sommet
mais il est temps pour un autre
constellation gouvernementale qui est la
thèmes dédiés à ceux des précédents
grande coalition pas assez abordée
[La musique]
ce serait oui
si vous supposez que cela reste ainsi
regarde oui ça voudrait dire oui alors
que cette grande coalition
sous la direction du SPD, c'est-à-dire sous la direction de
scholz devrait arriver
empêcher la cdu csu par tous les moyens
veulent donc une grande coalition sous
direction de
contrepartie du grand concurrent das
ne sera probablement pas dans la cdu/csu
être exécutoire